hi guys this is Rob from simply learn
and today I am going to tell you how you
can become any W solutions architect so
who is an AW Solutions Architect now the
main role of an AW Solutions Architect
is to help you deploy your applications
on the AWS platform now this is nothing
but a cloud computing platform so it's
not to say that you can't deploy your
applications on the cloud computing
platform yourself it's just that when it
comes to organizations the applications
that you need to deploy become a whole
lot more complex that's where an AW
Solutions Architect can help every sense
cloud computing became a thing companies
around the world have started migrating
their physical infrastructure onto the
cloud that's what a natively solutions
architect does they help you migrate
your physical infrastructure onto the
AWS cloud companies around the world
work on a budget and an AW Solutions
Architect will help design a cloud
infrastructure based on the
organization's budget before that can be
done however an AW Solutions Architect
has to create a design with an intricate
and detailed blueprint of the cloud
infrastructure that they plan to set up
now a w solutions architects also have
to focus mainly on non-functional
requirements like usability reliability
scalability and performance of the cloud
infrastructure they're also responsible
when it comes to minimizing risks that
an organization can face when it comes
to cloud computing platforms now they
could face risks like security leaks
calculation mistakes and application
down times any W solutions architect has
to ensure that these don't happen before
we can talk about how you can become an
AW solutions architect I have some
exciting news for you guys
we've launched our own YouTube community
you'll get to see a lot of quizzes polls
offers and much more to make your
learning experience a whole lot more fun
you can find all of this on your
subscription feed or you can also click
on the top right corner right now to get
started and let's get back to how can
you become any W solutions architect now
to become an AW certified Solutions
Architect
you need to clear the aw certified
Solutions Architect associate level
examination now here's some details
about it the exam score ranges from 100
mm marks and the minimum passing score
is 720 however there's a catch the
passing marks are actually set using
artistical analysis so they can be
changed based on how difficult the
examination actually is the exam fee is
$150 and you can also take a practice
examination which costs $20 now
regardless of the examination you take
be it solutions architect sis ops
administrator or developer any associate
level examination costs $150 for the
professional level examination it's $300
now if you want to learn more about the
aw certifications I suggest you click on
the top right corner and watch our video
aw certifications in ten minutes to
learn more now the exam duration is of
130 minutes and you have two types of
questions multiple choice and multiple
answer now the multiple choice questions
have four options or which one of them
is right and you have multiple answer
where you have five options or which two
of them are correct you can take the
examination in English Japanese Korean
and simplified Chinese now let's talk
about how you can schedule an
examination first let's go to Google and
search for AWS certifications click on
the first link
so on this page we can go to the bottom
and find the different certifications it
blaze provides click on architect and
select the a double-a certified
solutions architect associate
certification click on register now
and here you need to click on the aw
certification account
you can sign in with your Amazon account
or create a new one
I already have an Amazon account that
I'll be using for signing in here in
case you don't you can click on the
create your Amazon account button here
and create an account for yourself
you
now after that is done you can do a new
examination
and you can scroll down to the bottom
here a doubly certified Solutions
Architect associate level certification
click on shared your exam press Continue
and here you need to select your
language which I'm assuming is English
I'm from India so I don't need to change
anything here but you can join your
country your timezone and other details
based on your requirement and select
your preferred month I want to do it in
October
now select search for exam Center select
the one that's closest to you I'm going
to select this one and here you can
select the day that you want to take
your test and the time available I want
to do it on 15 you select the time that
I want and press continue now you can go
through all the details here change them
if you want to otherwise you can press
continue after this is done close and
here we have the final step which is the
fees
you can enter your details here and pay
now to finish the process now let's look
at an outline of the exam content now
what you going to see in the exam are
five major domains and here you have
each of the domains with their
respective weightages first you have at
34% designing resilient architectures at
24% you have both defining performing
architectures and specifying secure
applications and architectures a 10% you
have designing cost optimized
architectures and at 6% you have
defining operationally excellent
architectures now let's look at each of
these domains in detail now the first
domain or design resilient architectures
can be divided into four parts
firstly you need to know how you can
choose reliable or resilient storage
using services like a Tablas s3 AWS
glacier and a WCBS then you have how you
can design decoupling mechanisms using a
doubly services now this is possible
with the help of AWS SNS now these are
in the only services that enable this
these are just some of the services then
how you can design a multi tier
architecture solution now this is
important because you need to know how
you can create a solution that involves
several other services then you need to
know how you can design highly available
and fault tolerant architectures now for
the second domain defining performant
architectures first you have how to
choose performance storages and
databases services that are used are aw
RDS aw redshift and ADA bliss DynamoDB
the second step is how you can apply
caching to improve performance a service
that can be used for this is a double
e's ElastiCache third how you can design
solutions with elasticity and
scalability you have a double ace lambda
in the Bliss cloud watch an AWS data
pipeline now for the third domain which
is specifying secure applications and
architectures you need to know how you
can secure applications using services
like AWS inspector a blaze cloud trail
any wim you need to know how to secure
data using cloud HSM and it applies
macey and how you can define the
networking infrastructure using cloud
front VPC an elastic load balancer for
the fourth domain you have designing
cost optimized architectures firstly you
need to know how you can
design cost optimized compute solutions
you can use a double sec to elastic
beanstalk lambda any W slight sale then
you need to know how can design cost up
to my storage solutions using AWS s3
Galatia EBS and elastic file system and
the final domain to define operationally
excellent architectures you need to
setup design features and solutions that
enable operational excellence now some
of the features are that you perform
operations as chord you annotate
documentation you make frequent and
small reversible changes and anticipate
and tackle failures now let's have a
look at the job opportunities when it
comes to aw solutions architects now if
you have a look at this graph you can
see that he WS s always provided a lot
more job postings as compared to the
other two giants in the cloud computing
domain which are Microsoft Azure and
Google cloud platform now if you do a
little bit of research you'll find out
that there's a significant lacking of
experienced personnel when it comes to
AWS so I would suggest this is the best
time for you to get certified in AWS so
how can simply learn help you with your
aw certifications now we are on the
simple and on home page
you
and here we have the ADA place solutions
architect course
on this course which is the aw solutions
architects certification training course
we have 36 hours of instructor-led
training 20 hours of self-paced learning
16 live demos 3 simulation exams 3
hands-on practice projects and so much
more here our main emphasis is on making
sure that you have enough hands-on
experience with the services that you
crack the examination at your first
attempt
so here we also go through some of the
more important services that you need to
learn like I am VP CEC to s3 and so much
more
we'll also talk about databases
application services security practices
disaster recovery and so on
we even have practice examinations to
help you prepare for the real one and
with that we've reached the end of this
video I hope you guys found this
informative and helpful thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply learn hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here